[Música]
gracias gracias a todos ustedes por la
invitación estoy muy contenta estar aquí
en tijuana soy alex gonzález
expedicionario conferencista escritor
pero el día de hoy quiero compartir con
todos ustedes algo que yo creo que va a
ser la vuelta al mundo platicaba más
rápida de toda mi historia como
conferencista porque tengo pocos minutos
pero quiero hablarles acerca de mi
filosofía de vida hablar de 1350
ciudades del mundo haberla recorrido
haberlas conocido haber conocido
muchísimos personajes e incluso
personalidades reconocidas mundialmente
te enseñan cosas dicen que los viajes
ilustran y yo quiero hablarles acerca de
esta historia que se cuenta en dos
partes la primera de ellas al sufrir una
enfermedad que me deja postrado que
después de un milagro logro recuperarme
y a partir de ese proceso de sanación
surge una pregunta que cambió mi vida
totalmente espero que en este momento
también cambie la tuya y la pregunta es
la siguiente en este momento siendo la
persona que eres tuvieras un sueño que
fuera tan grande tan grande que de solo
pensar se te pone la piel chinita pero
siendo la persona que eres ahorita te
resultará imposible lograrlo
checa bien como te lo estoy preguntando
va de nuevo en este momento tuvieras un
sueño tan grande que siendo la persona
que eres te resultará imposible lograrlo
y es que la cuestión es que la mayoría
de nosotros desconocemos algo que es
importante que ahorita voy a explicar
cuando todos teníamos entre 7 y 8 años
con de todos éramos bonitos siempre nos
preguntaban los los adultos algo y era
mi hijito que quiere ser de grande
princesita que quiere ser de grande y la
cosa es que nosotros en aquel entonces
siempre soñábamos incluso levantábamos
nuestra vista y decíamos quiero ser
abogado quiero ser astronauta quiero ser
superhéroe quiero ser futbolista
cantante actriz como la otra ya que le
pregunto a mi hija tú qué quieres ser no
yo sólo quiero ser bonita entonces bueno
cada quien tiene su sueño de niño no
pero el problema es que empezamos a
crecer y empezamos a dejar de soñar como
niños es decir ahora los grandes la
parte más importante puesto que empiezan
a crecer en otro ambiente que no es el
de la niñez empiezan a crecer en dos
conceptos bien importantes que rigen una
zona que se llama la zona de confort
todos lo saben entonces en la zona de
confort como existen dos principios
básicos que rigen es que rigen esa zona
que es la seguridad y el miedo entonces
los sueños del niño ya no deja ya dejan
ser sueños de niño y empezamos a ver la
realidad y entonces empezamos a que nos
importe mucho el como el momento de
fijar metas cuando yo me hago la
pregunta que si todavía tuviera un sueño
que siendo la persona que era me
resultaba imposible lograrlo
estando postrado en una cama estando
desahuciado esperando la muerte dije una
vuelta al mundo sería un sueño
fantástico para mí pero tuve que dejar
de pensar en él como y empecé a soñar
como niño en donde sol en donde todo lo
que me importaba era simplemente sentir
lo que puede sentir una persona que
puede llegar a cumplir un sueño que
siendo la persona que es le resultará
imposible lograrlo
y empecé a soñar como niño donde el como
no me importaba ya finalmente yo estaba
esperando la muerte la vida la
oportunidad de la vida me devuelve la
vida logro levantarme de esta enfermedad
y decido hacer algo digno de dios
completar la vuelta al mundo en
bicicleta exigiéndome a mí convertirme
en alguien mejor para lograrlo es decir
deje de soñar como grande cuando empiezo
a practicarle a la gente sobre que
quería darle la vuelta al mundo qué
crees que pasó como la zona de confort
esta grandísima y el 95% la gente vive
aquí que creen que sucedió me empezaron
a dar respuestas en virtud del miedo y
la seguridad y me empezaron a decir al
estar loco como puede ser posible que un
mexicano pueda concebir una cosa así eso
déjaselo a alguien de por allá de donde
pues de otro lugar con qué bicicleta con
cuánto dinero cuántos idiomas hablas has
salido de baja california alguna vez no
pues no no no no cuánta gente lo ha
hecho no pues yo no sé creo que nadie y
tú crees que lo vas a hacer no no no
entonces yo cada vez que compartía mi
sueño le preguntaba a los de acá y todos
me decían por qué no entonces empecé a
darme cuenta que como eran personas
realistas
tal vez tenían razón hoy estás loco un
viaje a la vuelta al mundo no puede ser
posible que te está pasando pero
entonces ya cuando andaba así como que
me dio el down que creen que me
encuentra una persona que vive en la
zona
ahí va
aquí está la zona de confort pero me di
cuenta que existía un lugar donde tú
puedes estar también que se llama la
zona
espérate no traten de adivinar y sabes
por qué porque nadie te ha dicho que
existe otro lugar te han vendido como la
tierra prometida la zona de confort y tú
quieres llegar y aplastar te aquí
sabes como por qué porque te estaban
enseñando desde niño que si te da miedo
y aparte vas a perder tu seguridad pues
entonces es una locura entonces qué es
lo que sucede empiezo a descubrir que
aquí me empiezan a decir oye alessi a
puzzles que tú vas a ser el primero en
darle la vuelta bueno know it solo with
con un compañero bueno no importa pero
lo vas a hacer por primera vez pues sí
oye cómo le podemos hacer para ayudarte
dime qué hay que hacer no sé cuánto
cueste pero pues vamos a ver qué hacemos
y entonces me empiezo en ponderar y
empiezo a dar a entender que el plazo el
la vuelta al mundo si podría ser posible
entonces me doy cuenta que la razón
principio principal con la cual yo tenía
que dar es hacer ese viaje era para
decirle a los de allá que las cosas si
se pueden lograr
el asunto es que como la mayoría de la
gente les repito aquí crecen en la zona
de confort permanecen en la zona de
confort y mueren en la zona de confort
se casan y se tatúan dos conceptos
principales el miedo y la seguridad la
mayoría de las personas siempre me
preguntarles cómo fue que le diste la
vuelta al mundo pues muy sencillo
cambie la forma de jugar el juego cual
juego el de la vida y aquí empecé a
gobernar mi vida y a basar mis
decisiones en virtud de dos conceptos
que allá no se trabaja con ellos el amor
y la libertad cómo funciona eso se
escucha así como cursi no el amor y la
libertad tampoco no pero ay te va
ustedes saben
pero me preguntan hoy al eso yo te veo
así como que mira no te ves así como un
común rommel pacheco digamos no
cuál quieres que sea la virtud más
grande que tiene una persona que logra
dar la vuelta al mundo en bici muy
sencillo
soy valiente
nada más
soy he sido y seré valiente y saben por
qué porque descubrí en el viaje que el
mayor acto de amor que puede hacer una
persona es un acto de valor
descubrí ahí van las cosas que descubría
se me olvidó hasta el powerpoint me
cambió así lo voy a seguir las malas
y además ya no lo ocupo
[Risas]
y descubrí
que acá la gente cree en dios y una vida
que aprendí a dejar de creer en dios
y saben que aprendí mejor a confiar en
él
descubrí que si tengo miedo y estoy
perdiendo seguridad estoy en la zona de
confort que si estoy adquiriendo
libertad y todo está basado en virtud
del amor estoy convirtiendo en un hombre
valiente
entonces descubrir también que aquí la
gente siempre entiende mal el juego
porque porque aquí te enseñan a que la
zona de confort es un acz es un acto de
hacer los que están en la zona de
confort siempre están haciendo algo y le
doy y le doy y le doy y le doy
y los que estamos de este lado siempre
estamos siendo algo con s no con h aquí
se hace y acá se es
aquí la gente trabaja para dejar
herencias y aquí la gente trabaja para
dejar legados
entonces empiezo a viajar me empiezo a
enredar con todo este tipo de gente me
empieza a gustar este tipo de vida y
dije oye qué padre ser alex gonzález y
aparte andar en bicicleta que es lo que
me gusta mucho pues yo quiero hacer el
viaje inició la travesía con 80 dólares
y la compañía de un de un amigo que
decide vivirla
la aventura con migo y el día de la
salida el primer pedalazo se me sale la
cadena
entonces los de los de la zona de
confort porque porque tienen miedo y no
quieren perder su seguridad que crees
que dijeron no los dejen ir se van a
morir
detengamos a ver autoridades no más
preparados yo decía bueno con 80 dólares
creo que puedo darle la vuelta al mundo
por qué porque sé
y porque soy valiente
entonces empiezo a pedra le pongo la
cadena empezamos a salir y empiezo a la
travesía
45 mil 446 mil mil 350 ciudades 80
dólares de presupuesto
pues en yuma 66 millas de aquí bueno
aquí hace un poquito más
pues ya me quedaba la mitad
se acerca una persona me dice hoy a
dónde vas porque tras esa banderita o es
que como era el primer día le digo pues
te voy a mexicali excelente te estás
como a 100 kilómetros de llegar
y yo bueno yo es que lo me voy por este
lado y quiero llegar por acá
y yo no lo conozco luego si me voy a ir
por acá por acá sí sí sí sí voy a llegar
por aquel lado mexicalli sabes que te
faltó un chingo entonces
pero como aquí como aquí nosotros
siempre estamos cambiando para que la
gente de acá cumpla los sueños que creen
que hizo el cuate sabes que álex me
inspiras te te mueves con un ingenio
entusiasmo y por lo tanto pon tus manos
ahí y empieza a sacar monedas de 25
centavos fue lo que me pelaron del
casino pero ojalá te sirvan para cenar
diste y empiezo a recibir dinero y
empiezo a recibir ayuda
antes de salir al viaje de alguna lista
de personas que yo sabía que vivían aquí
o que yo creía que vivían aquí quería
conocerlas pero no sabía él como cuando
empiezo a compartirlo con la gente sobre
todo con los medios de comunicación me
decían alex estás bien loco cómo crees
que vas a poder estar reyes de españa el
rey de marruecos con futbolistas
basquetbolistas como michael jordan como
empresarios como bill gates como con
escritores como palo coelho cómo vas a
llegar con un marc ser manso con un
bernach y no el ganador del tour de
francia como un miguel indurain cinco
veces ganador del tour de francia cómo
vas a llegar con ellos no sabes cómo y
el asunto es que la mayoría de la gente
que vive aquí siempre quiere un porque
siempre está buscando respuestas y
nosotros los que estamos de este lado
siempre estamos encontrando en el para
qué definiendo el para qué
entonces yo empiezo a viajar y empiezo a
transformar vidas alrededor del viaje y
empiezo a darme cuenta de cosas
fantásticas de cosas que no pasan aquí
pero me empiezan a pasar acá
les voy a hablar de algunas
estoy parado frente al océano atlántico
primera vez que lo veía en mi vida cómo
está asociando atlántico que padre llegó
con llegar y conocerte
feliz contento llegó un señor y me dice
y qué estás haciendo aquí hoy es que me
gusta el parque para pasar este aquí en
la noche estoy viajando por el mundo y
este soy y este pues me gusta el lugar
parece un lugar seguro usted es el
velador señor el del parque no pues es
que en realidad no te metiste un parque
estás en mi mansión yo
pero bueno pues es que mucho aquí se ve
seguro bueno te pareces un hombre de
bien creo que mejor te quedas aquí qué
estás haciendo dando la vuelta al mundo
excelente
ojalá todos pudiéramos conocer el mundo
despacito como tú lo conoces yo conozco
muchas partes del mundo
pero si sería interesante que me
contaras a ver vamos bien cuenta cuenta
y empieza una gran amistad
paso por washington y la embajada me
dice el señor embajador usted tiene una
invitación para visitar la casa blanca
a ver si tiene oportunidad de saludar al
presidente de eeuu
me toca saludarlo y pongo en la lista
una palomita paso al abono y soy
participe en la organización de las
naciones unidas estudian la organización
de los estados americanos llegó a
chicago y me resulta que llegó
exactamente que cuando están jugando en
aquel entonces una final de los bulls
contra -utah jazz y me toca conocer a
michael jordan
y michael jordan frente a mí me dice
álex déjame decirte algo a ti porque yo
estaba paralizado de ver tan gran
personaje no
creo que se me hace más sencillo echarle
de tres puntos faltando dos décimas para
que acabe el juego que intentar dar la
vuelta al mundo te felicito estás de
este lado
lo mismo que me ha dicho el presidente
continuamos viaje de diego a detroit
michigan está aunque el gran premio de
troy y hay conozco a tres personas que
estaban en mi lista y que yo no sabía
cómo las iba a conocer pero en algún
lugar del mundo me los iba a hallar paul
newman walter payton el más grande
corredor del fútbol americano
y mario andretti
llegó hacia él y la organización de los
marineros de cielo me invita a lanzar la
primera bola en un partido de los
marineros de seattle y conozco a bill
gates
y lo primero que me pregunta qué sistema
operativo usas en la laptop me imagino
que traiciona laptop microsoft señor por
supuesto
[Risas]
porque porque sabía muy bien cuál era
bien producto y nadie me ganaba a vender
la vuelta al mundo como yo lo hacía
baja que viene el aceite va este
dinerito y así generan lo que es un
dinerito para el este
estoy a 20 km del aeropuerto en
vancouver para seguir mi viaje por japón
y me encuentro un japonés que resulta
que el dueño de una de las marcas que
traíamos portando en la bicicleta
y que me hace la mejor pregunta que le
puedes hacer a un ciclista saben cuál es
me pregunta ya comiste y saben con la
respuesta no
esta no falla siempre funciona
tomamos el vuelo a japón y empezamos
nuestro travesía por el lejano oriente
japón corea del norte y en el kilómetro
de 18.000 me cansé
fue la primera vez que quise estar de
este lado porque estaba cansado
y saben que me di cuenta que aquí en la
zona de confort nosotros estamos
acostumbrados a dar excusas y yo ya
estaba preparando mi excusa para
relajarme y regresar a baja california
y decía ok no lugar la vuelta al mundo
pero nadie de mexicalli ni de baja
california ha llegado hasta seguro en
bicicleta yo sí voy a hacer un chingón
de mi ciudad
y simplemente una lana está me van a
aplaudir
pero entonces empecé a recordar que de
este lado no damos excusas damos
resultados nada más
quizás porque es fácil dar resultados de
este lado porque es un asunto del ser
acá es un asunto del hacer
entonces yo no conozco uno que sea tan
fracasado como para que le encargue
sabes que lo único que quiere es que
seas tú mismo y fracase no puede
fracasar siendo tú el detalle es que no
sabemos que no sabemos por lo tanto si
no sabemos que no sabemos jamás vamos a
llegar aquí nos vamos a quedar con la
idea de que llegando a la zona de
confort llegue al cielo llegue a la
tierra prometida ya la hice como cuando
te dan la base en un trabajo
como cuando quieres sindicalizados
chingaste way
si me explico
pero vas a estar atrapado en un lugar
hermoso pero nada crece aquí
entonces cuando tú escuchas historias
extraordinarias de gente que las hace
aquí siendo ordinarios lo primero que
dice es ese güey me está mintiendo ese
gordito que está parado en el es que le
va a dar la vuelta al mundo
claro que no pero lo que no entienden es
que lo que cuenta aquí acá no cuenta
aquí no importa lo que estás haciendo
aquí no cuenta tus likes aquí no cuentan
que tampoco que tan que tan popular seas
aquí si cuenta eso pero acá no acá todo
va a llegar en su momento justo cuando
alcance su nivel de excelencia tal todo
va a llegar cuando tiene que llegar y lo
fui descubriendo el paso de los
kilómetros durante la travesía en el
kilómetro 18.000 les digo mira me estaba
cansando y jo letón que pedalear más
rápido porque acá falta un minuto
y dije ya se me voy a rajar
al momento la bicicleta y empiezo a
pensar en que solamente tengo que
pedalear 120 kilómetros para llegar a
seúl y relajarme me paso en milagro y
como yo soy un eterno eterno convencido
del poder de la oración pues yo estaba
esperando una señal y me pasó ese día un
coreano se acerca a decirme que estaba
estaba ahí en su casa yo le digo camps a
mi edad y él empieza a silbar el himno
en la alegría
y en ese sentimiento de esa letra tan
bella e inspiradora empiezo a llorar en
esta travesía y empiezo a darme cuenta
que lo que estaba haciendo era que me
estaban invitando a quedarme aquí
después de ahí sigo pedaleando enfrento
el desierto de gobi que es el desierto
más grande del mundo
a mí me pasan una serie de milagros
los himalayas treinta y tantos grados
bajo cero
afganistán pakistán irán irak
turquía grecia y en grecia me avisan que
rompo el tractor mundial de mayor
distancia hecha en bicicleta cuando no
era ni siquiera mi intención hacerlo
me convierto en el mejor del mundo en
algo
700 km antes de llegar a roma logró
poner la palomita al número 1 que tenía
en la lista y recibe un correo
electrónico que decía
estimado excelentísimo señor embajador
alejandro gonzález o sea yo
permítame informarle esa superioridad
que el estado vaticano ha accedido que
usted tenga un encuentro privado con su
santidad el papa juan pablo segundo
y yo empiezo a llorar
era que yo quería agradecerle
esta oportunidad de vida
y pedal y hasta ya sin saber el como
esperando a hacer algo con las cosas que
suceden porque aquí la gente siempre
está pidiéndole a dios que algo suceda
y le estás pidiendo y le estás pidiendo
pero acá yo entendí que hay que hacer
algo con las cosas que suceden
al encuentro con su santidad para firme
fue maravilloso
después de un año cuatro meses y diez
días concluye una vuelta al mundo la
primera que se tiene registrada yo
todavía no conozco a alguien que lo haga
ojalá que haya habido muchos
y me di cuenta que el mundo es un lugar
maravilloso que el mundo es un lugar en
donde tú puedes elegir estar con un
mismo escenario aquí o puedes estar acá
lo importante es que sigas dos
principios básicos y ahorita te los voy
a compartir para terminar con mi
participación
si sientes miedo y estás perdiendo
seguridad
si estás evitando el miedo gracias estás
en la zona de confort no te vas a ir al
infierno si te quedas aquí
es nomás dos lugares donde tú puede
estar
pero si tú quieres conocer la más grande
visión que alguna vez has concebido de
ti aunque te dé miedo imaginarla porque
es un ingrediente básico para entender
un sueño verdaderamente es decir que te
esté invitando inspirando obligando
acarreando teo arrastrando está que te
conviertas en una mejor persona
bienvenido a la zona mágica porque aquí
vas a descubrir la más la más grande
visión que alguna vez hayas concebido de
ti y como aquí el ego ya no cuenta sino
el estado del ser pleno entonces habrás
sido como todos los grandes líderes que
me dijeron habrás estado del otro lado
ojalá ojalá que la película ojalá que
todo lo que hacemos te llegue y en este
momento todavía tocado tu corazón por
favor te pido que no pienses no más
quiero que sientas y entenderás que la
zona mágica es una zona en la que tú
debes estar algún día ojalá que sea así
muchas gracias a usted
[Música]